7 30 a.m in harlem new york
the day gets off to an early start for
pupils at kipp schools they've got a lot
of learning to do they want to have a
chance of attending college
the sixth graders have a maths class
many students are african-american or
latino
most come from low-income families kipp
schools are often over-subscribed so
enrollment is determined by blind
lottery
richard barth has headed the kipp
foundation for nine years he knows the
importance of a good education
if you want to create a great school and
you want to provide transformational
education for kids where kids are
literally going from you know a starting
point where they're below grade level to
well above grade level teachers are it
so the correlation between great
teaching and outstanding results
you know unbelievably hot
so teachers here often resort to
unconventional methods to motivate their
students when you lie and you accuse
somebody of doing something that they
didn't do
you know the kids need to work hard so
it helps if their parents reinforce that
idea at home yes
they always told me to keep on studying
because they didn't get the chance to
study
and go graduate college but at least i
can
make the difference
ladies and gentlemen please welcome our
ceo mr richard park
hey there guys
richard barth pays regular visits to the
kipp schools there are now more than 160
spread over 20 states it is me against
you
here he's taking on eighth graders
during a maths lesson not major in math
okay
and um my most the the biggest question
i have right now mr lee is do i get
credit for putting my name
on to get like partial credit so
may the best person win
pupils first work on the problems
individually then discuss them in groups
but richard barth has to figure them out
on his own
he grew up in a middle class family and
later studied at harvard but maths was
never his favorite subject
and i haven't done math in a long math
like this in a long time i got the
addition and subtraction down this is
this is
we should have stopped with question one
early on bath realized that in the us
children from low-income families have
little chance of pursuing higher
education but these eighth graders have
beaten him
before i came to this school like my old
school was like really bad and my mom
she didn't like really like that i went
to diamond taco so she found out about
kip and then she put once she put me in
the school i like i changed like
dramatically
with
um
behavior grades wise
like epically and yeah i just want to
say thank you so keep it up i'd like to
come back again and maybe with a little
more prep knowing what you're studying
i'll do slightly better but have a great
day
i'm everyone we only did three questions
kids can do whatever you ask of them we
just have to ask
them to do more than we knew or more
than we thought they could do and that's
what we're seeing again again kids will
rise to challenge
um the
the kids are incredible it's the last 25
years this is i've been lucky enough to
be in this work
once a child has been admitted their
siblings automatically qualify for a
place at the school
for many families it's like winning the
lottery
the kipp schools receive government
funding like other charter schools in
the u.s but they also rely on
philanthropic donations securing them is
a major part of richard barth's work
he feels kipp schools play an important
role in promoting equal opportunity in
education still in this country where
you're born largely dictates whether
you're gonna have the opportunity to
attain a great education
eight out of ten children growing up in
the top income quartile
get a college degree
eight or ten percent of children growing
the bottom income quartile get a college
degree
this is happening
at a time of globalization this is
happening a time where the value in
earnings
the distance
in the in the value of earnings between
a high school degree and a college
degree is growing dramatically in
america
the management team gathers for a
meeting the first kipp school was
established 20 years ago in houston
texas today 59 000 pupils in the u.s
attend a kipp school over 90 percent of
them graduate from high school and most
of them go on to attend college
you